It’s pretty mind boggling that we spend
a third of our lives asleep, but scientists
still aren’t sure why we do it.
They know it’s important for resetting neural
activity, memory storage, rejuvenating our
bodies, all sorts of positive benefits.
We all do it, but we just don’t have any
conclusive answers on why it happens.
But thanks to genetic research we’re really
starting to figure things out on a molecular
level.
For instance, do you have a hard time getting
a good night's sleep?
According to scientists it’s all in your
genes.
Or, one gene in particular.
Researchers in Washington state were looking
for genes that changed expression throughout
your sleep-wake cycle.
And they found one in mouse brains: FABP7
- or fatty acid binding protein.
They found that mice who had a mutated or
“knocked out” FABP7 genes slept more fitfully,
compared to mice with normal genes.
The mutant sleepers were more likely to wake
up during the night.
Worst X-Men ever.
That suggests that this gene is required for
normal sleep ... it’s a sleep gene!
Now, testing in mice isn’t enough, so they
tested this in humans too -- and found the
same thing.
The U.S. researchers teamed up with scientists
in Japan and looked at data of 294 Japanese
men who underwent a sleep study.
It turns out that 29 of these dudes slept
fitfully AND had a mutation on FABP7.
They also tested this in fruit flies.
This is the first time researchers have gained
this level of insight into something as complicated
and mysterious as sleep across different species.
Plus, FABP7 is found in astrocytes, which
are star-shaped glial cells located in the
brain and spinal cord.
Astrocytes are total rock stars in the sleep
world.
They’re potentially responsible for creating
that sleepy feeling we all get when our brains
feel tired or overworked, astrocytes secrete
adenosine, which triggers sleep mode to protect
our brains.
So it’s no wonder that a mutated FABP7 found
in astrocytes can mess with our sleep.
But not all sleep gene mutations are created
equal!
Some can be to your advantage.
Are you the kind of person who can work for
long hours into the night, sleep six hours,
and wake up feeling refreshed?
LIKE ME?
A study published by researchers in California,
found that “low-sleep but high functioning”
people can do this because they have a mutation
in a gene called DEC2.
And according to the researchers, people with
this gene mutation were born to need less
sleep.
Whatever most brains need to do in 8 hours,
DEC2 brains can do in 6.
This class of “efficient sleepers” are
truly elite, only 5% of the population have
this mutation.
Scientists are even thinking of designing
a whole new class of drugs based on this mutation.
So, even though we’re getting close to deciphering
the molecular mechanisms behind sleep, it’s
still one of the biggest mysteries in our
shared experience.
And hopefully you’re not watching this before
you go to sleep because thinking about all
the millions of synapses functioning and eventually
powering down in your brain could keep you
up at night.
Plus, blue light on your phone.
That’s bad.
We can’t do episodes like this without our
sponsors.
Today, Seeker is brought to you by Squarespace.
Whether you need a domain, website, or online
store, make your next move with Squarespace.
Create a beautiful website or online store
with an award-winning template.
Start your free trial today, at Squarespace.com
and enter offer code SEEKER to get 10% off
your first purchase.
Go to sleep!
Just… don’t stay in bed too long…
Seriously don’t.
Check out this handsome devil to understand
why it’s dangerous to stay in bed too long.And
do you think you might have a mutant sleep
gene?
Let us know in the comments.
Subscribe.
Like this video, and thank you.